hello
uh i think you have to trust me because
i'm customer
and of course that that could be the
first sentence that quantum device may
say to you
right now
you have to you have to trust me yes
so i'm you yuan i'm from university of
michigan
so i'm going to assume
there's at least one evolutionary
biologist here
remotely online watching it
so i'm going to
assume
no prior knowledge and
and you may
in to avoid making you bored
i throw in some pictures that you like
so kuala lumpur is incredible
so it's incredible doing many things
spooky actions in the distance very
important movie
simulating quantum physics
super fast factoring
unbreakable codes nobody can bring it
there are more
but
because georgia was saying more i
couldn't understand what he says i think
it's blah blah blah
so the story began with this cat
um this is cat this is a cat in a slow
experiment of schrodinger social nice
cat
it is
it was a very miserable cat it was put
in this
metal box where there is a
chemical
and the chemical
is radioactive
so after some time
this cat and chemical
they become in a so-called entangled
state and if the chemical decay
the cat will eat that
yummy poison
and become dead
and if
it is not
it does not decay that a cat would be uh
craving for that poison but not eating
it so therefore life
do you actually believe
do you actually believe in half that
have a live cat how many have you been
in
not many
and that's what uh my student samina
felt when she took my
introductory conan computing course in
2002 so i went to michigan as assistant
professor at that time
so she was talented
many things and one of her talents write
poems so here's the poem here she wrote
it's one of the four points all the
poems are in my website okay
so i'm going to read to you
a group of physicists perform a hawks
about a cat
have a life have that in a box
the equations so well worked out
and observations to doubt
only mathematicians fall for such jokes
so indeed
quantum power is
incredible
incredible in a negative way
hard to believe
so there are reasons that we don't trust
the quantum devices
first of all we are classical beings
we can just touch
the cat and say yeah this is shorter as
you can you can't do that
and there are technological challenges
it's very hard
to make quantum computers
so i googled the record of factoring
using quantum computer
i think the current record is
the number
143
that's you
and even experiments
that are supposed to
verify their indeed quantum entanglement
are not conclusive you miss the best
joke
so there are loopholes for
entanglement experiments
and there are security concerns
this chip
us
alleged quantum chip
might be certified by
a simulator agency
and we don't know you trust it
uh depends on
the situation sometimes you may not want
to trust it
it's 11 13
yeah
you you are faster you are faster than
that corner computer
so um the question now becomes
now we don't trust we don't want to
charge the chrono device can we still
reap the benefit
of the quantum power
that's the main question that i'll try
to answer
and the answer is
yes we can
don't trust
this guy
but we still have to work with it and we
can make it work
so i'm going to start with
the journal principles and approach the
journal paradigm
of making untrusted quantifies work and
after that
i will talk about three applications
untrusted device quantum computation
untrusted device
randomness extraction
and then untrusted device key
distribution
i probably will spend most time
on the second
topic
now i'm going to start to describe the
general framework or general approach of
making
untrusted quantum device work
the foundation is what i called
classical test of a quantum duck
so
if this works like a quantum dot
crack like a quantum duck
and behave like a quantum dot
then
you will be a quantum doc
so
the classical text test will be
interactions between the users we are
classical being
with the untranslated device
and we will check if it behaves
like a quantum uh duck
um
and the test we're gonna we will perform
they will have the property
that
if
the device is behaving
exactly like an ideal quantum dock
then it must be the ideal device
and furthermore
this notion of
robust self-testing this is the noisy
version of the the previous self-testing
if the device is behaving close to
the optimal quantum strategy
then the inner working of the device
must be close to
the ideal quantum device
both in the quantum state and also in
the measurement
up to some local uh
isometry
okay so that's the the first part
the first of the two most important
ingredients in the general framework
self-testing
so suppose we have some game to do a
self-test how can we make use of it
the strategy is to
mix
work and play
if you have children how do you make
your children
do the house work at the same time
enjoying it
that's a challenge if you can accomplish
that that's great accomplishment
and that's precisely
uh those results i'm going to survey
accomplish mixed
work and play
the consequence is that
the device
cannot tell if it is work or play
it cannot tell if this work or test and
if it tries to avoid work
you will risk
fading the test
so
the protocol
will have the following two guarantees
the first one is called completeness
guarantee
it says that
if a device is honest
therefore the job is well done then we
should pause the device
with overwhelming probability
then the second property is sound is
property
it says that on any device
good or bad
our protocol
almost always reject
or
accept
a very well done job
so combined with the completeness
it implies that all right so if
uh the device is honest
um then we will possibly uh sorry uh it
implies that if you press that the
chance of
us
being fooled
by a malicious device is very small
okay so
i have finished describing these two
important ingredients
in making untrusted device work one is
self-testing the other is to come up
with a strategy of mixing uh work and
play
and
so now
let's look into uh more details how can
we make this strategy work
um so come back to self-testing so how
could
how could surface thing be possible
okay
so um
it's impossible
if there's no additional constraints on
a device
if a device can do whatever he wants
then there's no way
we can accomplish our our goal because
uh it will just tell you whatever you
like to hear
some of you may know the story
so therefore we need to impose
additional constraints
on the device
and here's one
particular way of enforcing additional
constraint
spatial separation so we can recall that
the device
has multiple parts and we place those
different parts for
far away from each other
so that
because of special relativity
these two parts or multiple parts
they cannot communicate with each other
within a short period of time
that we will run part of our protocol
so this is a
constraint that classical beings like us
can
enforce
okay so now i'm going to look at a i'm
going to give you three examples of
self-testing
uh the first one is the ch so called
chsh game named after
the authors of the idea
the game works like this
we have a device that's two parts
a and b
so when a game starts
each part receives
one single bit so this part a receives a
x and part b receives y
and each part is required to output one
bit so aim outputs this little a
and part b outputs little b
and throughout this process
because einstein is in between
there's no
communication between these two
parts of the device
so the rule of the game
is the following when the input x and y
are uniform random
and so the device will win
if their output bit
x the xor of the upper bits is the same
as the end
of the two input bits in other words
when one of x and y is zero
then a and b
must be the same to win again
and if x y equals one
a and b must be different to win a game
so here is a very obvious classical
strategy
out of the four combinations three
uh
three has a zero in its input so
therefore
uh
if as if both a and b outputs zero all
the time
they will win three out of four
cases
it turns out that the best class code
winning strategy
is uh no more than uh three-quarters and
that can be achieved so this bond saying
that the best cost of winning
probability is upper bound by some
number this is called a bell type
inequality
and
as we have just
described as there's a strategy to
accomplish
to reach this three-quarters chance
so for quantum devices they could play
the game
in a broader way they could start
sharing
entanglement before the game starts
and then
once the game starts
each
of the two parts applies a local
measurement
uh determined by
its input
and there's a qua so uh
tyresen proved that the best quantum
winning probability is no more than this
number and cosine square of half a so
that's zero that's 0.85
and and this can be achieved
by a protocol we also call it chsh
particle
chsshkm is a strong self-test
so
in the 90s people already knew
that
any strategy
winning with that optimal quantum
strategy
must be the optimal quantum strategy
and more recently
oh
we knew
that it's a robust self-test
and
furthermore is the strongest possible
robust
self-test
in general
and if the winner probability is epsilon
closed optimal then both the state and
the measurements
are square epsilon close to optimal
and that's the strongest possible
yes
why do you call it self test i am
puzzled by the expression so who is self
the einstein itself or the a and b
uh i think it's just historical reason
we call it self test
i wasn't the first one to uh to describe
this but i think uh
i think the meaning is there's a reason
for for calling it uh so um
the validity of the devices can be
demonstrated by its own behavior
instead of we
take up take away the hook and look
inside
okay
i think uh
image
and ben richard and anger they call it a
rigid
rigidity of the game that's also
excellent name as well
so there are many other
robot self tests
for example there's a famous
ghz game and one reason that this is uh
very interesting and important is
the optimal quantum strategy actually
always wins
uh well the optimal classical strategy
is still
below one probability
there's this class of binary excel games
where the input and output are binary
bits
and
uh whether or not
the device when it wins the game depends
on the xor
of
uh the upper bits uh of course it
depends on the input but it also depends
on the xor of the output bits instead of
individual alphabet
so those are called binary xor games gcc
chsh both are examples of binary excel
games
uh so carl and i categorized
the class of
strong self-test
binary excel games there is a very
simple
criterion for deciding if a game is a
strong
self-test
so that's my first example
uh one short
one short test of
one shot self so self test of one shot
chsh game so how about we play the game
multiple times we play game sequentially
and what can we infer
from
the average
winning probability if the average
winning probability is close optimal can
we what can we say about uh
the untrusted device
so um
richard angela and vazinali prove that
if on average
this sequence of game
wins very close to optimal
then there's a big trunk
so for a random
chunk
of sequential games
of substantial length
then is close to
the tensor product strategy the
principle of the ideal strategy
so
this is the consequence is very strong
because it
it says that
uh for this trunk of gameplays
uh
this geology
is very close to tensorflow the form and
and therefore you can
substitute the property
of using a tensor product strategy
in situations that
when we have guaranteed that
this will happen
yes this is a repetition or a sequential
repetition
what would you say well this was proven
sequential sequential
well the fact that you
the fact that you separate the fact that
there's no in between
games uh communication without
differentiated from the usual notion of
sequential
so for for power repetition it's not if
you're clear that you cannot
get better
than
the
product so
here it's clear that it cannot get
better is it clear or
then it should be a sequential
repetition
so that's my second example of
step testing my third example is
separating graph states
so graph states are quantum states that
corresponds to graphs suppose you have a
graph like here
then a graph state in a graph state for
this graph
each vertex corresponds to a qubit
and each edge corresponds to some
indirection or some operation will apply
to those two qubits
so graph cells can be highly entangled
very complicated states
and so mckay proved like uh
graph states our robust cell testing
and
in the recent paper he proved that
in the graph state
so if it sorry if a
multiple multiple part device is passing
uh
the test with high probability
uh then
uh
the corresponding error
uh
in a strategy
is upper-bounded by a function linear in
the number of vertices so in his
previous work
the lumbar velocities appears as
exponential
function you improve that to
nina and that's important yes
the test is a okay it's two parts
no no it's not coming it's basically
testing if they satisfy the stabilizer
relation okay yeah
sorry
what is the graph state what is
what is it
what is the graph sheet um
you can you can see so there are two
ways these two ways to describe it one
way is this so i will start
with the state where each qubit is zero
state okay
i apply a holomart on each qubit
then for each edge
i apply
a control phase flip meaning if they're
both one i change the sign by minus one
okay another way to d okay so this is a
very explicit way of deconstructing it
uh another way to think about it it's a
is a state
that is stabilized
by
a group of party operators where this
group says you have
sigma x on each vertex and
sigma z on the neighbor on its neighbor
so for any of those it will stay but
stabilize this
state
can you write it down like some of
something sure
it's some
of
if the vertex has v
so
this is a zero one
uh
string indicating which vertex is chosen
and then the sine
is either plus or minus one depending on
if the sub graph induced by v prime has
an even or number of edges
okay and i didn't normalize the state
yes
so the
the what you're testing in the previous
in the chsh is both the state and the
measurement right and here it sounds
like you the measurement is you're
taking that for granted no no it's also
testing the measurement it also yeah
it was then
the measurements was a single cube
single qubit measurements right okay
yeah poly measurements
okay um
i think i'm gonna skip how you can do
uncharted quantum
computation based on those self-test
results because i have additional
materials
i want to focus on
so um
maybe i should mention uh the untrust
device quantum computation there are two
main two main results that uh
i would i have planned to tell you one
is
based on sequential
chsh
and the other
is based on
graph state actually i i regret what i
just said because i think they're very
important results so and
i'll just go back to where i left
okay
now how can we do untrust device quantum
computation based on those self-testing
results
i want to first set up the the
background
and
so the first step is to separate the
quantities the quantum
the essential quantum part from
quantum computation
um kind of extract the essential quantum
part and before i talk about that i want
to give you an energy
say randomized algorithm so one can
think about randomized errors as
every step you toss a coin and decide on
what to do next
an alternative
view is that
random magicalism is nothing but a
deterministical zone
that has an additional
input being random bits
okay so likewise in quantum computation
there are there are ways to separate
quantum
quantumness or quantum resource
from the computation
uh we can
we can uh equivalently express quantism
as some very restricted quant operations
like single qubit measurement
that are applied to some special quantum
resource which does not depend on the
input
so
here's one way of implementing this
separation of the essential quantities
and
restricted operations
and this is computation by teleportation
by contestant and charm
the quantum resource
is
a bunch of epr pairs very special
two qubit quantum states
and the restricted quantum operations
they are
bail measurements for single qubit
operations
now here is a high level description of
the richard anger bazini
untrust device qualification
so the untrusted device has two parts a
and b
and an idea implementation would have a
lot of aprs in there
the protocol
will mix so the
the user
is a randomized classical verifier
and he will
interact with both a and b
part a and part b
and the strategy is to mix
the sequential
chss test
which work for
teleportation based
uh computation
so if
the a par and b part are not following
instructions they will risk failing the
test
and always implementation would just
implementing just carry out the
instruction and should be passed with
hyperbole
so moving on to the quantum computation
and translates quantum computation
uh using graph state
so the corresponding separation of
quantum needs
from quantum mutation
is
uh the so-called one-way quantum
computer where you start with the graph
state and then you do
a
single qubit adaptive measurement on a
graph state
i have explained our graph state uh
uh what across a is so now uh the
quantum device has many many parts
in fact each vertex
is a device component
and so therefore
each component for avertx would not
communicate with other
vertex component
in a protocol
so the protocol
consists of a single message to
each component and a single mesh message
back from each component
and again so
the
strategy is to mix tests with work
and so on these devices restore
the gigantic graph state
and just apply
just apply the instructed measurement
so the difference with
the
uh richard anger was the only protocol
is that here
uh
it's one wrong parallely one wrong one
one bit one message
forward one message uh back but in
previous protocols it's interactive and
two only two parts of inner device yes
right the numprovers here is multiple
the number of components is
uh
basically the uh the size of the circuit
being simulated but in in reality very
simply
two two parts yeah that's a very
important difference
it's kind of traded between the number
of approvers
and the payroll
the number of runs
okay so let's finish my first uh example
of application of a trusted device i'm
moving on to the second
uh group of applications
uh about generating random numbers using
a choice current device
so randomness is very important it's
vital for modern day
information processing
so it's vital for
digital security
for
randomized algorithms and for scientific
simulations such as weather
prediction
whether for cars
and for gambling and many other things
so this is what we hope for
um for randomness
we hope that we can get very high
quality randomness and close to uniform
so it's it's quantified by how close it
is to uniform
uh sorry about that and
and also um
how
secure it is
it's also important aspect of high
quality
and we also want to have a large
quantity of it
and actually i did estimate i talked to
my
computer security guy
where random numbers are used in uh
in
in the current technology so of course
they are used in
uh
the public keys right but those are only
tiny portion of the total number random
bits we use
because every time you have a encrypted
uh
web
section uh session uh you would have
used random bits and in fact every uh
packet would have the packet number is
also supposed to be random number and i
did a calculation uh maybe one trillion
if one trillion bits a day in the whole
world is is too much it probably would
not be too old would not be uh one or
two negative well uh away so we need a
lot of
uh
around it
we also hope to minimize the assumptions
we make
about the random number generator
and
and we don't want to trust if we don't
have to
so currently uh this is one example how
we get random numbers uh so
linux is run in a lot of devices
including uh your
mobile phone if it runs android
so uh linux random number generator is
this so it's a deterministic uh process
it will collect inputs from the system
boot time from the current process id
and from user input
and and and and from uh hardware like
intel's own chip uh
uh
instruction there is an instruction
called rdd brand
that is based on some thermal noise
according to intel
so you collect all those inputs
and somehow mix them together
and then
uh to get initial randomness and
whenever the system whenever your
application needs a red number uh you
would
deterministic produce one uh so
therefore after collecting the input
uh you will apply some uh pseudorandom
number generation stretching and the key
to a longer key
the string to a longer string
so how does it do in our world uh there
have been numerous reports many reports
of
things go wrong
and the lack of initial randomness
has led to a large number of broken keys
so i have a colleague
alex harleman so he's he and his
collaborators they downloaded a lot of
keys from internet and they they broke
about one percent of the rsa or dsa keys
because a lot of those kids the sheer
factors
it's very hard to factor a number but if
you have two numbers sharing a key
sharing a factor it's very easy to find
them right so and and they explain that
they're only a small number of device
makers for
those devices and
and it turns out that a lot of them just
get the same initial randomness
and
there are news reports that
there are back doors built-in chips
and also in even in standard
and
also the security of current regular
majority they are based on improved
computational assumptions so therefore
vulnerable to
uh progresses in in algorithms and in uh
in technology
okay so here's the question so you have
a random majority
how can we be sure the output is random
it's not just a very practical question
it's also a
physical question and maybe a
philosophical question
so how can we
how could
fundamentally unpredictable events have
are possible in our world okay so random
number generator is creating some events
right so in a physical world how could
this kind of
unpredictable unpredictable event
possible at all so where do we get
initial
almost perfect randomness
the answer is that uh we can be sure we
and we never we can never be sure
so anybody knows where this picture
comes from
so uh what if we are all
our subjects of some experiment and
everything and the fact i'm talking here
is determine
maybe it's the bigger moment
maybe petra could have a better story
so we can't really be sure
without believing in something
first of all we have to believe
that randomness
exists gonna sound like a matrix
character saying um maybe most is uh
saying so we can't be sure
we can be sure yeah the output of a
randomness extractor is
is random
without
uh
accepting assumptions
so um now the key question is now
becomes the firm question so how can we
generate a large number of
probably unconditional secure random
bits
with minimum
with with minimal assumptions
so that's that's the central question
we're going to study
so let's look at
how classical theory
deals this problem
and i wouldn't
unclaim that the classic theory is
inadequate
because of the foreign requirement
it requires
having two or more
independent
sources
so the critical theory of randomness
extraction
it models with randomness
as
min entropy
string
so imagine this term and z is providing
you
some randomness
and uh
managing miniature b means that
uh the universe if the mean energy is k
that means that the anniversary cannot
predict
with more than two t minus k per bt
so the theory
has a theorem that says that
so randomness extraction
meaning that getting all uh almost ideal
uh almost i code almost uniform output
it's possible
only when you have two or more
independent sources so one may coming
from these chains in the army coming
from simpson
and they must be independent okay
how can we be sure that two sources are
independent
it's just impossible there is there's
some argument to argue that it's just
impossible
for dismissal to to tell if two sources
are dependent or not okay so if we have
to rely on classical theory
we have to
make sure that two sources are
independent but it's impossible to do
so here's a big question can we get
around
can we get around this independent
independence requirement
this is yes
if we trust quantum devices then it
solves almost all problems
in fact there are commercial products
and the reason is that the possibilities
of quantum mechanics
have
randomness building
it promises to randomness
for example if we prepare the state in
this plot state zero plus one and we
measure using the so-called computation
basis then we get output zero or one
with equal probability
and
this is probably one of the most simple
state to prepare so therefore you can
get
a lot of randomness out cheaply
and there are commercial products
available this is a product that takes
this from the website of id quantique so
they have
multiple lines of product uh
claiming
generating randomness is true quantum
enemies
and what is kind of here is
passes
a ll or
randomness test i'm not sure
what a qualifier qualifies but
all of the tests that they have done
and it claims to be high rate and
cheap
meaning that is quite easy
and whatever other property and down
there it says that this product has been
officially certified
by the swiss
government organization it's not three
data it's four letters organization
but the problem is okay
uh
should we trust the device so we trust
the device
not being malicious should we trust that
device working properly uh should we
trust the device maker and should we
trust the trust the four-letter agency
certifying that device
so institutions that we don't trust then
we want to
come up with methods for random getting
randomness from untraceable device
so there are two topics
two problems people have studied
on how to get randomness from untrusted
chronic device
those are in both way initiated by
kobach
with different collaborators
the first problem is called randomness
amplification
it was first proposed by quebec render
2012.
so um
the question is is
suppose
we don't have perfect enemies in our
disposal and what we have is an sv
source sends out vaseline rna source the
sense of razzing irony source
is a
is a big string where every bit
is of
some amount of buyers
and some amount of randomness
condition on all previous bits
so it's not perfectly random
but it's probably the closest to perfect
random
oh sorry
so we have sv source
that's the only random
source we have and we have untrusted
devices
so can we
make use of those sv source string
and interact with untrusted devices and
i'll put
one bit that is near perfect randomness
so that's the question they started uh
and they call it the randomness
amplification
and they have some physical motivation
for that purpose
the other problem is called randomness
expansion
it appears in quebec's thesis in 2006
and also in a general paper with his
advisor kent
in 2011.
so now we have we indeed we have perfect
underneath
going to get more
after making use some untrusted chrono
device
it is two questions people have started
in the past
so my
collaborators
caiman chang and charlie who is sitting
here
uh we have this framework for
extracting untrusted quantum device
exchange randomness out of untrusted
quality device so i'm going to describe
this framework
so this is part of a this is this is
going to be in qip
coming qrp
so in this framework
they are
a few so here are the players that and
and
components of in our framework there's
an anniversary
who is all-powerful but um
we are going to assume quantum mechanics
and the anniversary prepares the device
and may entangle with the device
and then you will shoot over you will
give the device to the user
okay
so after the adversary hands over a
device did the device
it cannot talk it cannot communicate
with the device and it cannot change the
device
after our protocol starts
but in okay so it may be set up to be
correlated with uh
anniversary
herself
the device has multiple components
and the user is a deterministic
classical being it can restrict the
communication among different device
components
so we have anniversary
and device and user and there's a fourth
thing
there's a mean energy source this is
classical randomly source and we really
need to have
some randomness
that
the anniversary cannot totally predict
because if adversary if there's no
additional randomness
uh
what because the user is dynamic
deterministic and
so the anniversary can
manipulate
the user
in any way that he wants so we need to
have additional randomness that the
anniversary cannot predict
um
so
therefore in our framework
this deterministic user is going to take
in this miniature resource interact with
multiple component with different
components of the device and at the end
you will
output
an out random
string and together with a decision to
accept or reject the protocol
so we can see
the previous two problems amplification
and expansion in this framework
so for amplification
remember recall that for a randomness
amplification problem we start with an
sv source going through and trust device
and outputting
a bit
okay
so
this is a special case of our framework
where
we are doing randomness extraction
that has no seed so in this iteration of
random-based extraction
seed
is
always a as in
in most also with in the proceed as
perfectly random stream
so therefore uh
this case corresponds to
seedless extraction
where
this tractor
has
an sv source
to assist its work of extracting
randomize from the quantum device
okay so there's no preference available
that's why we call it seedless
extraction
and so see this extraction is impossible
for classical extractors
so if
unless you have additional
independent uh
source so see this extraction using only
once one source is impossible that's
that's basically deterministic
extraction so we know deterministic
instruction is not possible
uh the first example is the sv uh source
example so see this extraction with
single
source is deterministic extraction which
is impossible classically
but
in a quantum setting it is possible it's
a big conscious
so the second problem of randomness
expansion
so recall that here we start with
private underneath we want to get more
out of interacting with untraceable
device
in our framework
it is precisely a seeded extraction
so this this classical
source is a perfect random
string and it's the seed to assist
the extractor
to get random outputs
so i want to emphasize a different
different view of this framework and the
previous two
problems
so in the previous
problems people think about the
randomness that we get at the end
came from
this classical source but here we
we think more appropriately we should
consider the randomness being inside
the intrasecond device
and
the role of
the classical
bnt input is to assist
the protocol
in unlocking
those hidden
randomness in the corner device
so with this framework let me describe
a list of
ideal properties we want to have
for
this kind of extraction yes so during
the extraction are you communicating
back and forth with the device yes yes
yeah there will be
uh back and forth interactions
yes so it's not just that you get some
kind of string from the device and then
you are turning it into a random string
but rather
you are kind of testing
the device
right we're going to test it
yeah i'm going to give you more more
more a little more details
okay so so what are the uh
nice properties we should have for
extracting randomness out of untrusted
one device the first one is security
ideally we want to have the strongest
possible security which is quantum
security security against
quantum
adversary
second is quality we want to have
negligible errors
negligible continuous error and
negligible sun is there
and i should point out the sinus error
is limited by the min hp source because
once the adversary can guess correctly
what that mean entry source is
there's no security at all okay so
there's a limit there's a limit for some
zero and we're going to we want to
approach that in it
so recall that
sony's error refers to
when the device is malicious
then what's the chance of us being
fooled of accepting something that's
really bad okay and
and there's a limit
determined by the miniature p
classical source and we won't ideally
want to reach that
thank you
the third
list the third item in our wishlist is
the output length
we want to output a very long random
string
and
ideally we want to extract all the
randomness hidden
in that uncharted device and i have to
say that it's not clear to me it is one
of the open problems
uh what exactly is the full capacity
of randomness that can be extracted from
a untrusted device
or idea or suppose you you fix an
implementation you fix a
um
an ideal implementation what exactly is
the maximum amount the randomness that
can be checked out and that's that's
they're not quantified
the fourth item in our
uh wish list
is for the classical source
we want to be able to work with an
arbitrary
uh a journal management source instead
of restricting the source to be
something that have additional structure
like sv source we're going to work with
all general
management source
and we hope that
everything else being equal
we want to use the minimum the smallest
miniature resource
so those four things are
in my basic list so i have a separate
list that i call premium list
and those items are critical for
protocol implementations
robustness
you should tolerate
a constant level device in precision
both in each basic operations
and also in uh fighting against the
coherence
so
if we have a protocol that works
only when the devices are
perfect or almost perfect
then in practice is going to be very
difficult
for us to pass
the ideal um a onus implementation
so it's very critical
for practical implementation that the
protocol tolerates noise
the next item is efficiency
and there are different aspects of
efficiency
we want to minimize the lumbar devices
they could be expensive
or
enforcing communicate no communication
between
of different
devices different parts may be expensive
so only minimize device number
and computation it also should be
efficient
we don't
we don't want
uh
so you'll be very undesirable if the
protocol requires a large
quantum memory that will store the
quantum state for a long time okay
and the smaller
uh the requirement is the better
so those are in my
premium list of the wishlist for uh
randomness extractors
extracting from
untrusted one device
sorry i i guess you had only one device
uh sure okay
good right right um
uh okay so um
um
if you have more than one devices so
it's possible those devices are
correlated so therefore is not it does
not satisfy the classical assumption of
independence so we do have to consider
situations that you have multiple
devices and i guess um
i think i'm i'm using convention that
a device could have multiple components
and then some other ulcers they would
think about each component as individual
devices so
my convention is if i have multiple
devices uh when one device is is working
there should not be communication
between this device and other devices so
i think either way so thinking about
each component as one device is fine but
my convention is that when i use
multiple devices
then when one device is being used
there's no communication between it and
the other devices
okay thank you
um
so um
all right so we have these two problems
people studied
amplification expansion and they
correspond to
seed seedless
extraction and seed extraction
so let me first focus on seeded
extraction
um
so in this area my experience is that
the protocol after uh
this important paper wasn't in vdick
and the protocol is kind of obvious
but the difficulty is improving is it
works
so the protocol of those works are more
or less the same so let me just describe
this general framework
so in this framework we have one
device and it has two components
and the protocol consists of playing
sequential
chssh games or maybe some other games
and
the protocol will make use of the random
bits
now it's uniform runner bits because we
are doing seeded extraction
making use of those bits to choose a
subset of those games
for
testing okay so the device cannot
predict which game is chosen
for testing
and the other games will just be
the other games would be
generating games with games that we use
to generate randomness
so in a test round
the user will feed
the device components
random input but in the generating round
you will use some constant input
okay so therefore uh in the testing run
it will consume additional randomness
but in the long testing run in the in a
randomly charging run you will not
consume additional randomness
in a protocol aborts
when the device
is losing
too many
test runs
otherwise succeed
so what's the relation of
self-testing and generating random
numbers it turns out that the optimal
quantum strategy
has a property that
the output bit a
is uniform
to all parties of course if a is known
to
the device
and
device a
device component a but other than the
device component
a is just random
to everybody okay
and by strong self-testing property
if
um
the strategy is close to optimal
then this alphabet a is close to uniform
to hold
okay so that's a basic
building block
for those particles
so let me describe intuition why it
works
and and then after this i'm going to
jump to
uh i'm going to fly in quantum speed
uh to uh one slide and then i will
conclude
so um the intuition why this work is
this
so here's here's a diagram for testing
wrong one of those four combinations is
chosen
to play the game but in the generating
wrong only this fixed input is is chosen
so you see there's the intersection of
these two sets of possibilities or i
mean
this pair zero zero also appears with
one quarter chance in the testing round
so if
a malicious device
is playing smart and trying to cheat
when
he sees zero then he risk
losing the test
so therefore
um
trying to cheat will risk losing
a failure in the test
as a consequence
the winning ratio of the testing rounds
um
uh because because those states and runs
are are are chosen randomly so the the
winning ratio of those second rounds
is a good estimate of the winning ratio
for the georgian rounds
and
and strong self-testing ensures that
the output is random intuitively that's
the intuition that if suppose now the
protocol does not abort that means that
in testing rounds
uh the device is winning uh very close
to optimal
and another by this statement implies
that in the journey around a large
fraction of a general run are also close
to optimal strategy so that and then if
if the strategy is closely optimal that
bit is close to uh uniform output so it
seems to putting all everything together
uh
if many wrong if many of those changing
rounds strategy are closed optimal then
the output should be
random
okay
but actual proof is
is very difficult in fact i'm not sure
if this is actually true
so
intuitively it sounds reasonable
but mathematically carrying out the
proof is very challenging
okay
maybe i just mentioned that uh this this
uh work of carl
sitting here at me
uh we accomplished
uh similar
we cover similar uh parameters
with versailles so from k uniform bits
we can output
exponential in k upper bits
with exponential
in k to some power
error
and
and this is when n is
uh
a large number uh and so of course we
need to have have this number of
quantum results to start these are the
additional features we accomplished is
our protocol is robust
and so that means that each game needs
to win with optimal
with some universal constant below
optimal quantum strategy
and we also allow
in-between runs
communication for the device so there's
a button of device office wrong we can
press the button allow them talk to
instead of establishing a fresh copy of
epr pairs for example
and consequently we don't recall
uh
maintaining
establishing
a lot of entanglement supposedly when
not put a minion bits
so now we don't have to prepare one
million per epr
and and we don't we don't have to
maintain them in that state for the
whole process
and we don't
uh we also allow
any game from this class of strong
self-test
to be used as a building block
and also
this protocol translates directly to qkd
so we can do
a key distribution
with untrusted
uh two-part device or multiple part
device
and at the same time expanding
randomness
uh i'm going to jump to
um
sure um
and translation i mean the
translation to q ready
so um
all right so this protocol you have two
parts right imagine that uh in the qrkd
setting alice has this part and bob has
this part
and they're gonna simulate this particle
okay and a lot of a lot of discussions
will be public okay
now it turns out that our protocol
would still work
so if it is above simulate this random
expansion protocol
uh with some careful adjustment
especially in the
classical post-processing part
then what it can accomplish is that they
can start with k random bits
in the end they will share a key
of exponential in k
number of bits
and using a choice sequence device and
it's secure with the security parameter
of that
now i have talked about cd extraction i
didn't have time to talk about the c
list extraction
but i will just
talk about
the combination of these two works
yes i will try to finish
so yeah
can i continue my question sure how is
it related to like there are
other techniques for doing device to
depend quantum key distribution
so this is just another way of achieving
the same
um okay good question i think the other
known protocol of okay so i know of only
one other protocol achieving
untrusted device quantum contribution
that is robust and which is by faster
energy
in 2013.
so there
uh to output n
and bitkey
the initial randomness that is above
need to share is also linear in n
okay and the difference here is that uh
we can start with
body log of n
our sharing is any air we get uh
and bits out and but the share property
is that quantum secure and it's robust
and one additional difference is that we
we also allow
any
uh strong self-test in our building
block and because our expansion protocol
allows that and the vasanova protocol
uh
uses a specific uh game
so i'm looking for
all right
so the protocol i just described by
miller and and me
do uh it does seal this
um
sorry seeded extraction city extraction
um
and the other protocol that i didn't
have time to explain
uh this uh accomplish
uh series extraction so combining them
together what we can accomplish in
forming
so imagine that
the only randomness you have is a
miniature resource of certain k-mean
entropy
so through this protocol
um
we can produce linear in k bits
of random string which is random to a
device that will be
in this particle
okay so the the university might know
quite a bit about this but it's okay the
important thing is that this is random
this is random for devices
so after the ms protocol we can get n
bits out
and
this n and k
there's no relation between them in
other words
n can be absolutely long
and so start from k-mean entropy
source we can get unbounded number of
bits out
so the importance of k
is in
the quality parameter so how close our n
bits are
to the uniform and bits and that is a
a number
that determined by k so we almost
reached the limit of exponential in k
okay
um
and the protocol is robust and it's
built based on
an arbitrary strong self-test
so um
i should just finish and
i'm going to be here all the time
many days so
i have a lot of open programs
i consider some of those some of the
most important problems
in our area so feel free to talk to me
i'll be happy to share with you those
problems okay thank you
any more questions for yaya
yes and
the major results open problems
okay um good question
oh
i think it's different people may give
you different answers
so for me
um
okay so i have a list of problems
but here's if you have if you ask me for
a single one
here's a conjecture
so earlier i started to go back
so this protocol
that does seed this extraction
is not very efficient
it make use of a lot of devices
and
and running time is it's not very good
so if you if you require that the output
the parameter the the quality parameter
is
is um
is of uh cryptographic uh
quality
then the time compressor is not
efficient either okay so my conjecture
is that
we can use two device
one device two component one device
to do the whole thing to the combination
meaning that you could maybe you could
modify it new language protocol
so that instead of starting with
uniform
c you start with k minus r seed so
source
then you can get the almost perfect uh
remnant
and
that's my favorite problem at this point
and of course other problems are include
negative results what's the limit so i
have this wish list for this new
framework and there are a lot of
parameters so what are the is there a is
there a single
optimal
extraction particle where everything is
optimized or maybe there are
incomparable
extraction protocols
some multiple in some way some other
optimized some other way so finding out
the limit
would be my other favorite problems yes
i have a question are there games
national games that don't have good self
tests
uh sure i think we can we can yeah we
can
construct those games what are they what
do they look like or uh so basically
suppose even if you restrict to
um
binary excel games right
so one-on-one has so the self-testing
property depends on basically the
property of a polynomial
associated with
the game and you can construct a
polynomial in such a way
so that you can get
any
behavior of self-testing
carl would you agree with me yeah yeah
so so i guess trivial examples would be
games where the maximum classical score
is the same as the next one quantum
score those are not self-tests but then
there are also ones where the maximal
quantum score is higher but they're
actually multiple different strategies
that will achieve that score okay those
are not some tests
okay so i have to add another important
problem i feel very important very
fascinating and it's more abstract so
the randomness extraction is more
practical right
the object problem is to characterize
all
self-testing games or all robust
circulation games and we have found out
classes like binary exo games there's
some subclass of being
strongly safe destiny and for graph
stage we also have a uh the class of
states being self-testing
and what are the most general class of
games let's see if testing and a lot of
protocols we work with i don't feel that
a specific game used
is important so it's a so the intuition
behind how they work is very general so
there must be some very simple
property making those things work
and
so asking this broad as so categorizing
all the self-testing of strong
self-testing games i think will be a
step of identifying essential features
not make all those untrust device
protocols work and that to me is very
important fundamental question
can you do this untrusted uh randomness
expansion
i mean self-testing does self-testing
and pure and all protocols we've seen so
far for it definitely yeah
so um
the proof card i
critically rely on
our characterization of what is a strong
cell path
now there is a geometric explanation
like i'll be better than explaining that
and
it's a it was magical that uh that
probably turns out to be critical for
for our proof
the unit is something about geometric
picture of uh oh okay yeah i mean so
like
with a self-testing guarantees is that
um any given
strategy so if so if your score is
within epsilon of being optimal then
there's one particular strategy that the
device must be using must be using
something very close to that one optimal
strategy and what that means in this
context is
any measurement that the
adversary could perform on an external
quantum environment will give her very
little information about what strategy
was used by the device because whatever
was contained in the device is very
close to this one optimal not entangled
not a strategy that has no outside
entanglement
strategy and so um so that's sort of the
basis for
making the conclusion that the adversary
gets very little information for making
the conclusion that it is
secure
it kind of feels like an eigenvalue gap
kind of thing
yeah i mean it is a little like that
yeah i think that's also kind of where
the the o of root epsilon uh error
estimate comes from because it's a lot
like the maximum eigenvalue of an
operator
so a consequence of what car described
is that for those
strong self-test scans it turns out that
any any device
we'll have to
would have a honest component an honest
measurement component
just by the property of the game
yeah
and that's an important step in our
proof
all right let's think about it again